man kids nowadays they have it easy bro
all these medicinal shops opening up all
over the city I remember was before the
medicinal shops came in I have to buy
drugs from kids who are still in high
school so so embarassing man people
thought I was there to pick up a kid but
most people thought I was just being a
pedophile standing there behind the gate
for something little homie really how is
it
you sure the right amount
cuz that someone kind of short what it's
always right it's always right all right
you see that kid over there he's a
genius
he's smart and [ __ ] like Doogie Howser
I'm sure the genius because I really
friendly math and I don't think I
already got $60 I'm gonna pay though
it's only if as his teacher hates and
bro all right all right man Tyler I'm
sorry and um I'm uh making cookies to
make it up man I was looking into this
delivery service called speed weed what
we should do something like that here
I don't think speed we've something a
good name if it's not like they're
they're different speed it does it
should be like slow weed delivery slowly
delivery with fast pace with a
fast-paced fast-paced slow weed delivery
fast-paced yeah can't even say that but
yeah I know a couple of kids that could
deliver that stuff for us perfect new
skateboard
y'all